>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> It's a great privilege for me
to be here today to introduce one
of the finest writers on the staff
of the Washington Post, Wil Haygood.
What distinguishes
Wil, as those of you
who have read his newspaper writing
or his several excellent biographies
will know, is his exquisite sense
of history and his
pitch-perfect ear for dialect.
He is brilliant at describing
the unsubtle tectonics of race
in our land and he's possessed
of a wise empathetic voice
that subordinates itself
to the narrative.
His writing never overpowers the
extraordinary tales that Wil likes
to tell of other people's
remarkable lives
yet Wil's own life story
is one for our times too.
He's a child of Columbus, Ohio where
he was a self-described product
of a simple boyhood overlaid by a
complicated family, a story he told
in a memoir, The Haygood's of
Columbus, a love the story.
He didn't set out to be a writer.
In fact, he majored in city planning
during the 1970's which thus
to be old enough to
remember or recall that was
when the New York Daily News ran the
headline, Ford to City: Drop Dead.
New York may not have
taken a hint but Wil did.
He switched over and took a
management training program
in a big department store
from which he was soon fired.
He jokes he was reading
books in the stockroom
which may have been good
training for what came next.
He figured if he couldn't make it
in retail he could
always try journalism.
It was a goof fit.
He worked his work for the
Charleston West Virginia Gazette,
the Boston Globe, and for the
last 20 years or so for The Post
where he's now on a national staff.
One of his unique talents
is describing the lives
that are the threads and
the tapestry of our times.
Some like Sammy Davis Jr. and Adam
Clayton Powell Jr. are famous.
Others are less so.
Three days after President
Obama's inauguration,
Wil wrote a memorable
profile of Eugene Allen,
a black man as Wil put it, unknown
to the headlines who had never
in all his years serving as a White
House butler imagined he would see
someone who looked like
him in the White House.
The book Wil will talk about
today is Sweet Thunder.
His biography of Sugar Ray Robinson,
the boxer and cultural icon
and owner of a famous pink
Cadillac that I will let Wil explain
if he wishes, please
join me in welcoming Wil
to the national book festival.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you and welcome and
certainly on a day like this I know
that the executive editor of the
Washington Post has a million
and one things he could be doing, so
I'm quite touched that he took time
to come out here to introduce me.
Somebody just asked me a
few minutes ago if I grew
up fighting in a gym, boxing.
And I've been trying to tell
ladies from the second grade
on that I consider myself much
more of a lover than a fighter.
[ Laughter ]
>> But there was one experience
I had in the boxing ring
in my hometown in Columbus,
Ohio I was in the 16th grade
and somebody talked to me into
stepping into the boxing ring.
I might make the team if I
was fast enough in the ring.
And the other person hit me
very hard and I went down.
And the pain went in one ear down
my back, down the back of my leg,
over to the other side of my body
and I'm still feeling
that pain today.
So no, I never became a boxer, but I
had a lot of admiration for somebody
who had a life as fascinating
outside of the ring
as they did inside of the ring.
And while this book is
a book about a fighter,
Sugar Ray Robinson it
really is much more it's a--
what I like to think it's
about as Langston Hues put it,
the sweet flypaper of life.
Sugar Ray Robinson had 3
very dear friends in Harlem.
They were Langston Hues,
Lena Horne, and Miles Davis.
And a lot of this book is about
the wonderful cultural swirl
that Sugar Ray Robinson made happen.
A lot of the night clubs in New
York City in the 30's and 40's
as you know were segregated
and so Sugar Ray Robinson took
it upon himself with his earnings
from the ring to build a nightclub
that was called Sugar Ray's.
It was very elegant and folk
could come all races, all hues.
They could come and sit down and not
worry about the color of their skin
and that in turn proved
to the wonderful Jazz giants
Duke Ellington, Sammy Davis Jr.
who is an entertainer and others
that Sugar Ray's was the
place to be in Harlem.
I went on a book tour and I'm
just gonna tell you about 2 things
that happened that standout
a great deal and made me know
that the 5 years I spent on
this book were well worth it.
I was interviewing somebody and they
said you have to go find Mel Dick.
And I said, who is Mel Dick?
And this person said "well, Mel Dick
knew Sugar Ray Robinson for many,
many, man y years more than 35
years and he's some place in Florida
and you must find Mel Dick.
It's going to add a lot to this
story that you're trying to tell.
And so I was able to track Mel
Dick down in Miami, Florida
and this is Mel Dick's story.
When he was 8 years old he
lived in Brooklyn, New York.
He played hooky from school, he
went into New York City to a gym,
Steelman's gym where Sugar Ray
Robinson happen to be sparring.
Now, Mel Dick is white, and he told
me this story when I found him,
and he was the lone white kid
in the gym that day just sitting
in the audience watching
Sugar Ray Robinson spar.
He played hooky from school
and he didn't tell his mom
and dad where he was going.
Sugar Ray Robinson noticed him
out on the corner of his eye
and after he was finished sparring,
he walked down and was talking
to the other people, and he bent
down and asked Mel Dick who he was.
And he said, "Sir, my Melvin Dick,"
and he said, "Why are you here?
And where's your mom and dad?"
And he said, "Well, my mom
and dad they're at home
and they do not know that I'm here."
And Sugar Ray Robinson said,
"Well, why are you here?
For heaven's sake,
why are you here?"
And he looked up at Sugar
Ray Robinson and he said,
"Because you're my
hero, and I love you."
And for the next 45 years, Mel Dick
and Sugar Ray Robinson were
extremely, extremely close.
Sugar Ray Robinson was the
best man at Mel Dick's wedding.
Mel Dick was there along
with Miles Davis in 1965
when Sugar Ray Robinson at the age
of 40 plus fought his last bout
and it was just a beautiful moment
to find somebody from their youth
on up who had known
Sugar Ray Robinson.
And the second great moment for
me as a writer happened in Ailey,
Georgia and that's where
Sugar Ray Robinson was born,
although he was only there for a few
months and then his family took him
up north in Michigan, and
then from Michigan to Harlem.
And I went to Atlanta, Georgia on
the book tour to give a reading
and the Atlanta officials took me
the next morning to Ailey, Georgia.
A little, small rural community
and I'm thinking as we're driving
over that goodness there might not
be anybody there for the simple fact
that Sugar Ray Robinson had
left when he was 4 months old.
And we drive and we roll into this
little tiny town in a little library
on the side of the road
and they had a marquee.
And on the marquee it said, "Ailey,
Georgia welcomes Wil Haygood."
That may be the only time in my life
that my name will be on a marquee.
I appreciated it though.
Now, there were--
[ Applause ]
>> There were about 125
people in the lot next
to this little library just milling
about, men, women, mostly men
and women and they
were milling about.
And my thinking is that, "Gee,
something must be going
on at the library.
I wonder what it is."
And I got out of the
car and I was in a suit.
If you're gonna write a book about
Sugar Ray Robinson, you have to go
out and buy some nice
suits for the simple fact
that Sugar Ray Robinson was a
very elegant guy dressed very
beautifully, wore pink Cadillac
I mean drove a pink Cadillac.
It was an era of lushness, his life
was an era of just true elegance
and grace and lots of poetry.
But anyway, a man in the
parking lot walks over to me
and he has a very deep
southern voice and says to me,
"Would you by any chance
be the author?"
And I said, "Well,
yes, sir, I am, I am."
And he said, wonderful.
He said, "We're all Sugar
Ray Robinson's relatives
and we have come out to
walk you into the library."
And I was so, so very touched.
It was just wonderful and when I
got into the library, you know,
I was just so enormously touched.
I started reading and there were
about 130 seats, so it really was me
and Sugar Ray Robinson's family,
and I would read certain sections,
and they would yell back at me.
"That's right, Sugar.
Hit him, Sugar.
Amen, Lord have mercy.
That's my sugar.
That boy was something else.
And I'm reading, I'm looking out
at them, really, oh wow, hey, Amen.
Lord, hit him, Sugar."
So those two experiences were
worth being away, you know,
on your little book advance
that you get, you know,
hoping that your editor is gonna
welcome you back into the newsroom
after the several years of-- you
know of hard work on the book.
But it has been worth it, and
ever-- every sense of the word.
This is the final book of what I
like to think of as a trio of books
about unheralded or lost
figures you might say in history.
There was Adam Clayton Powell,
there was Sammy Davis Jr.,
and Sugar Ray Robinson.
They're are all figures who I think
put a little more of the red, white,
and blue in this country and
made a unique difference.
So thank you, and I guess we'll
open it up for some questions.
[ Applause ]
>> I was curious, how many
women played a serious,
significant role in his life?
>> In Sugar Ray Robinson's life?
>> Yeah.
>> Yes, his mother, Layla
Walker was a very fierce lady.
Sugar Ray Robinson used to
go outside when he was a kid,
8 or 9 years old and
he would get beat up
and he would be crying
and he would go home.
And his mother would say,
"Don't come in here crying.
Go back outside and fight."
So in a real sense, his mother sort
of shoved him into the fight game.
I think Sugar Ray Robinson if
he would have had his brothers,
he would have been an entertainer,
he actually left boxing for 3 years
and became a hoofer, a dancer.
He wasn't very good at it and then
in 1954 he went back to fighting.
But his mother was, you know,
very important in his psyche.
>> Were there a lot of
women attracted to him?
Pursuing him [laughs].
>> Oh, oh ladies, ladies.
You're talking about the
ladies in the nightclubs, okay.
I was a little slow on that one.
[Laughter] Okay, ahh, you know,
as with all flamboyant figures
and as Raymond Chandler once
put it, there's always a lady
in Sugar Ray Robinson's life.
I think there were a
lot of women around,
although he only had two
marriages, and he died married
to his second wife, Millie,
out in Los Angeles so.
Okay I'll go over here.
>> First of all, thank you
very much for the book.
I thoroughly enjoyed it.
>> Thank you.
>> I too idolized Sugar Ray
Robinson when I was a kid.
I still can't believe
he lost to Joey Maxim.
But I wondered if you could
compare his cultural impact
with Muhammad Ali's?
>> Uhmm. Well, now I
mean, great question.
I think one of the main reasons why
Sugar Ray Robinson somewhat got lost
in history was that another fighter
who fought in the 1960 Olympics
in Rome, he came along and
the TV age was just starting
to explode you might say.
And Ali really, really sort of wiped
Sugar Ray Robinson from a lot of--
a lot of our-- not memory
but a lot of our visual love,
Sugar Ray Robinson should have been
on those night talk shows like,
you know, or the daytime talk shows
like Merv Griffin or Phil Donahue
or whatever you had
in the 60s and 70s.
But then you had this huge figure, a
cultural bullet across our airways,
Ali, and in a way, Sugar Ray
Robinson receded he moved to L.A.
and he started a youth
foundation which is--
which was just wonderful because in
his youth foundation the kids could
do a lot.
They could dance.
They could play the
piano, badminton, checkers,
they could paint but
there was no boxing.
There was no boxing.
Sugar Ray Robinson did not want to
have a child get into a boxing match
and go home and not have a father
open the door and tell the son
that everything's going
to be all right
because Sugar Ray Robinson's
father was not under his roof.
And so that's very telling and
actually that was one of the reasons
that made me want to
really write this book.
Sugar Ray Robinson was a fighter.
He founded a youth program and
you could do anything you wanted
to almost in that program
except box.
Okay, I'll go over here.
>> Okay, hi.
Two questions.
>> Uhmm.
>> Maybe you've implicitly
answered it in terms
of the physical toll of boxing.
We know football players have
serious problems like get banged
on the head and we've seen some
horrendous consequences of boxing.
So I wanted to ask what Sugar
Ray thought about all that?
And if I could veer to Sammy
Davis Jr. and your other books,
what real depth of knowledge
did he have of Judaism?
He converted and that
was always talked about,
but I wonder what it
really meant to him in terms
if his knowledge and his commitment?
>> Okay, that question is you
know is just a big layered,
layered question and there's
not enough time to the answer.
But you'll find the answer in a
book called, "In Black and White:
The Life of Sammy Davis Jr."
[ Laughter ]
>> Okay.
>> Your first question about boxing.
>> Yeah.
>> Sugar Ray Robinson I
think foresaw all of this
that boxing was a very brutal sport.
In 1947 he went to Cleveland, Ohio
he fought a guy named Jimmy Doyle.
Jimmy Doyle had suffered
some severe knockouts
in the State of California.
He shouldn't have been
boxing in the State of Ohio,
but he was allowed to box.
This was in 1947.
Sugar Ray hit him with a punch
in the chin and it killed him.
Sugar Ray was threatened with arrest
and a charge of manslaughter in 1947
and so he knew that
boxing took an awful toll
on fighters, but he
lived in America.
It was segregated at the time.
There was no jobs on Wall Street
for blacks, no jobs in banks, few,
few, few jobs in Hollywood.
And so boxing was one way
where a black man could become
somewhat wealth, and so Joe Louis,
Henry Armstrong, other fighters
they took that risk knowing that.
Now, I might add that after
Sugar Ray Robinson killed Doyle,
he took a tour and fought
four times and raised money
because Doyle was fighting
to buy his mother a house,
and Sugar Ray was struck to the core
that Jimmy Doyle died fighting
to buy his mom a house.
So Sugar Ray Robinson went
and fought four fighters
and they were tough fighters,
but he gave his winnings
to Jimmy Doyle's mother so
that she could buy her house.
I just think it's a very touching
part of his life, his history.
>> Thank you.
>> Over here.
>> Hi Mr. Haygood.
>> Hi.
>> I like your point
about three of the kind
of forgotten people
in American history.
I just finished a master's thesis
at Georgetown University
on Nathan Hale.
One of the, I think forgotten
heroes of American history.
My question is I don't
know if it's been asked
but who gave Sugar Ray's name?
Where did that come from?
>> Okay, great question.
He was born Walker
Smith Jr. Walker Smith,
Jr. I think that the ladies liked
Sugar Ray Robinson a little more
than Walker Smith Jr. But
anyway, he was a young fighter
on a young boxing team based in
a church in Harlem and they went
into Watertown, New York to fight.
He was just 15-years-old
and there was a fighter
on the team named Ray Robinson,
but Ray Robinson got sick
and so young Walker
asked the manager,
George Gainford, if he could go on.
If he fight in Ray
Robinson's-- his place.
George Gainford didn't
think he was good enough,
but the young Walker
Smith browbeating
in the locker rooms said,
"Coach, please, let me fight.
Please I'm ready."
Walker Smith fights but George
Gainford, the manager has
to change the name
on the fight card.
He has to-- he doesn't have an extra
fight card so he uses the fight card
that said Ray Robinson, and he told
the referee that the kid stepping
into the ring now is Ray Robinson.
So he fought and he
knocked the other kid out.
I mean, boom, boom, boom.
His skill was apparent even then.
There was a sports editor named Jack
Case from the Watertown newspaper.
Jack Case asked the manager,
Gainford, who was that fighter
and because he sure is sweet.
And he said, "Well, his
name is Ray Robinson."
When Jack Case hustles
back into the newsroom,
he makes up the name
Sugar, sweet as sugar.
So he makes up the name, Sugar
Ray Robinson scores knockout
at arena and the name stuck.
>> Thank you.
>> Okay. Yes.
>> Hi, at one time professional
boxers were really at the core
of the American consciousness.
They were the real cultural icons.
Joe Louis, Sugar Ray
Robinson, Muhammad Ali.
I have to admit, I haven't a clue
who the heavyweight
boxing champion is today.
What has happened that there's
no longer Sugar Ray Robinson's
or at least Sugar Ray
Robinson coming out of boxing?
>> Well, I think that in the
40's and the 50's boxing was
like NCAA football is now.
It was epic.
There were fights fought outdoors,
there were stadiums that were,
you know, full of people,
100,000 people.
They were fought at night.
It was stunning to see
two figures in a ring.
Radio was big.
The rivalries were big.
Joe Louis, Mash Melling [phonetic],
Jake LaMotta, Sugar Ray Robinson;
these figures were sort
of larger than life,
and I think because of the simple
fact that we have more sports now
that are seen by more people and
the fight game has suffered so much
as far as integrity, honor-- it's
just really suffered something
that it hasn't been
able to come back from,
and thus we really don't
follow fighters the way we used
to follow fighters in
the 50's and the 60's.
And I mean that was
one reason why I wanted
to spend years unraveling
Sugar Ray Robinson's life.
He was a big, big deal in
the 40's, 50's, and 60's
and yet he sort of vanished.
And I just think that we found
other sports to watch and, you know,
so many comically and tragic
things have happened with fighters,
heavyweight fighters especially over
the last 15 years that it's hard
to sometimes take it seriously.
>> Okay. I'll go over here.
>> Hi Mr. Haygood.
>> Hi.
>> Just first of all I want
to say congratulations to you
for being nominated for the 2010
Hurston/Wright Award for nonfiction
for your book and also for the--
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
>> Also for being nominated
or being a runner up rather
for the PEN/ESPN award
for sports writing.
Thank you very much.
>> Thank you.
>> I really enjoy the book.
I'm a writer so I'm gonna
ask a writer question.
>> Okay.
>> All of your biographies, they're
so nuanced and their so layered
and you give us so many things about
so many people in Sweet Thunder.
We found out not only about Sugar
Ray Robinson but we also found
about Lena Horne, Miles Davis.
I mean you were able
to put so much into it.
How do you keep all those thousands
of bits of information flowing
to be able to make a
really coherent and inviting
for the reader; first question.
Second question is what
are you working on now?
>> Okay, thank you.
Thank you so much.
She said some wonderful
things that I swear I hope
that all the people
back in the 5th grade
who said I would never
amount to anything.
I hope they heard that and I hope
their watching C-span today and--
[ Applause ]
>> I hope that they heard that.
Anyway, these figures, and it's
interesting when I wanted to,
you know, like have Lena
Horne and Miles Davis
and Langston Hughes swirling
throughout the narrative.
My editor, Peter, gathers
wondered if it would work.
And I said, well, let me
write the first 50 pages
and I think you'll see
what I'm trying to do.
And you know, they all were
of the same time periods.
You know, and they all, you know,
sort of flourished and worked
in Harlem and so that made it easier
but I did have a wall in my home
and up on the wall it
would say something
like Sugar Ray Robinson, 1947.
And then I would have a
big piece of wall paper
and it would ask me I
would write the question,
what is Lena doing in 1947?
And then under that I would ask
the question where is Miles Davis
at in 1947 and then I would say
where is Langston Hughes at in 1947?
And then you know it skips ahead
and then I bring the reader
up to what Langston and Lena
and Miles are doing
say in 1953, you know.
And so I knew that every--
every 50 pages or so I wanted
to remind the reader that there's
this wonderful cultural swirl
going on.
It really is a book about
all the things going
on outside of the boxing ring.
You know if you think it's
only a book about violence
and blood and boxing, it is not.
It really is a book about
poetry, about music, about dance,
about night life, about
nightclubs, about New York City,
about Los Angeles, about Chicago.
It's a book about America
and how she danced and sang
with these people in the
middle of the spokes wheel.
Okay, question over here?
Sorry I can't hear.
Something is wrong.
>> Hi, can you hear me now?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah there we go.
I'm a big fan.
Thank you, you always
gift us with your words.
I have a quick question.
>> Thank you.
>> Which is just how do you choose
your subjects for biography?
Adam Clayton Powell, you
know, Sugar Ray Robinson,
Sammy Davis Jr. just wondering
what is it that a figure would have
to possess to get Wil Haygood
to take on their lives?
And then I will cede
the rest of my time
to the gentlewoman
from North Carolina.
>> My quick question is why
did you become a journalist,
and how has that training affected
the books that you've written
like the Sugar Ray Robinson book?
>> Okay, thank you.
Last questions over here
and the first one how did
i choose the subjects?
Real quick answer, New York
Congressman, Adam Clayton Powell,
was you know a force on the hill.
He went to congress in
1944 and left in 1970.
He was big on the student loan
program and I would not have gone
to college were it not for the
student loan program and so
in the back of my mind, I just said
to myself one day many
years ago I simply wanted
to pay a debt back to
Adam Clayton Powell.
And you know, it really was
a dream as simple as that
and so that's how that
book was birthed.
Sammy Davis Jr. when
I was little growing
up in the 60s there was
not very many blacks on TV
and Sammy Davis Jr. was one of
those figures who was my mother
and my grandmother who raised me,
they would call me in the house
and say, "Sammy Davis Jr. is on
TV, Sammy Davis Jr. is on TV"
and so he meant something to them.
And so I just sort of told myself it
would be interesting to write a book
about Sammy Davis Jr. some day.
These are figures who happened
to have had a lot of scandal
in their lives and they were
sort of burdened with scandal and
yet there was something heroic
about Adam Clayton Powell,
Sammy Davis Jr. and
Sugar Ray Robinson.
I told you at the beginning
about the punch that I took
that I'm still feeling, so
I wrote this book to figure
out where that punch came from.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.